you know it's unfortunate that politics
has become so serious
back when you were little was a lot more
fun you can make fun of politicians
here's a politician some of you may
recognize but it's convenient to be able
to vary what this particular politician
looks like for example we can go from
cookie Baker to radical we can go from
superwoman to bimbo socialite I'll type
a socialite into this there she is
or we can move the slider over the other
way get to bag lady
alert asleep sad happy how do how does
how does that work I don't know but I
bet by the end of this hour you'll know
how that works and not only that you'll
understand something about what it takes
to recognize faces it turns out that
some theories of face recognition are
based on the same principles that this
some that this program is based on but
you can kind of guess what's happening
here there are several many stored
images and when I move those sliders
it's interpolating amongst them so
that's how that works
but the main subject of today is this
matter of recognizing objects faces
could be the objects but they don't have
to be this could be an object that you
might want to recognize and I want to
talk to you a little bit about the
history of this problem and where it
stands today still not solved but it's
an interesting exercise to see how the
attempts at solution have evolved slowly
over the past 30 years so slowly in fact
that I think if someone told me how
we're
how long it would take to get to where
we are thirty years ago I think I would
have hung myself but things do move
slowly and it's important to see how
slowly they move because they will
continue to move slowly in the future
and you have to understand that that's
the way things work sometimes so to
start this all off we have to go back to
the ideas of the legendary David Marr
who dropped dead from leukemia in about
1980 I say the Gospel according to Mark
as he was such a powerful and central
figure that almost anything he said was
believed by a large collection of
devotees but Mara articulated a set of
ideas about how computer vision would
work that started off by suggesting that
with the input from the camera you form
a kind of look for edges and you find
edge fragments and normally they
wouldn't be even as even as well drawn
as I've done them now or as badly drawn
as I've done them now but the first step
then in visual recognition would be to
form this edge based description of
what's out there in the world and more
I'll call that the primal sketch from
the PI primal sketch the next step was
to decorate the primal sketch with some
vectors some surface normals showing
where the faces on the object were
oriented he called that the two and a
half D Sketch
well why is it two and a half d well
it's it's sort of 2d in the sense that
it's still camera centric and it's its
way of presenting information but at the
same time in attempts to say something
about the three-dimensional or
arrangement of the faces so the
speculation was that you couldn't get to
where you wanted to go in one step so
you needed several steps to get from the
image to something that you could
recognize and the third step was to
convert the primals they to an empty
sketch into generalised cylinders and
the idea is this if you have a regular
cylinder you can think of it as a as a
circular area moving along an axis like
so so that's a description of a cylinder
a circular area moving along an axis you
can get a different kind of cylinder if
you go along the same axis but you allow
the size of the circle to change as you
go so for example if you were to
describe a wine bottle there would be a
function of distance along the axis that
would shrink thee the circle
appropriately to match the dimensions of
a wine bottle a fine burgundy I perceive
in any case this one once converted into
a generalized cylinder when matched
against the library of such descriptions
results in recognition great theory
based on the idea that you start off by
looking at edges and you end up in
several steps of transformation
producing something that you can look
you can look up in a library of
descriptions great idea trouble is
now we can make it work it was too hard
to do this it was too hard to do that
and the generalized cylinder is produced
if any we're to course you couldn't tell
the difference between a Ford in a
Chevrolet or between a Volkswagen and
Cadillac because it is too coarse so
although it was a great idea based on
the idea that you have to do recognition
in several transformations of
representational a representational
apparatus just didn't work so much later
maybe fifteen years later or so we get
to the next the next part of our story
which is the alignment theory alignment
theories most notably the one produced
by Shimon Ullman one of them our
students so the alignment theory of
recognition is based on a very strange
and exotic idea it doesn't seem strange
and exotic to mechanical engineers for a
while because they're used to mechanical
drawings but here's the strange and
miraculous idea imagine this object you
take three pictures of it you can
reconstruct any view of that object now
I have to be a little bit careful about
how I say that first of all some of the
vertexes are not visible in the views
that you have so of course you can't do
anything with those so let's say that we
have a transparent object where you can
see all the vertexes if you have three
pictures of that you can reconstruct any
view of that object now I have to be a
little careful about how I say that
because it's not true what's true is you
can produce any view of that an
orthographic projection so if you're
close enough to the object that you get
perspective it doesn't work but for the
most part you can neglect perspective
after you get about two and a half times
as far away as the object is big and you
can presume that you've got orthographic
projection so that's a strange and
exotic idea so how can you make a
recognition Theory out of that so let me
show you
well here's one drawing of the object I
need two more oh let's see let's have
this one and maybe one this tilt it up a
little bit it's important that these
it's important that these pictures not
be not be just rotations in one axis
because they wouldn't form what you
might think that was a kind of basis set
so there are three pictures we'll call
them a B and C and then we want a fourth
picture which will look like this
doesn't have to be too precise and we'll
call that the unknown that what we
really want to know is if the unknown is
the same object that these three
pictures were made from so let me begin
with an assertion I'll need four colors
of chalk to make this assertion what I
want to do is I want to I want to pick a
particular place on the object like this
one and maybe the same place on this
object over here those are corresponding
places right so I can now write an
equation that the x-coordinate of that
unknown object is equal to oh I don't
know alpha X of a plus alpha plus beta I
mean X and B plus gamma X sub C plus
some constant talk well of course that's
obviously true because I'm letting you
take those alpha beta gamma and taw and
make them anything you want
so although that's conspicuously
obviously true it's not interesting so
let me take another point
and of course I can write the same
equation down for this for this purple
point and now that I'm on a roll and
having a great deal of fun with this I
can take this point I make a blue
equation and you know I'm destined to do
it so I've got one more color I might as
well use it let's just make sure I get
something that works here that's this
one it's this one I hope I've got these
for some spots is right we got one off
which one which color okay so this one
goes with this one goes with this one
but is that one wrong
Oh horses huh excuse me goes down here
right and then this one is off as well I
wouldn't get a very good recognition
scheme if I can't get those
correspondences right which is some one
of the lessons of today okay now I've
got them right and now that equation is
correct I think I've got this one right
already
so now I can just write that down I'm on
a roll I could just I'm just copying
this
so those are a bunch of equations and
now the astonishing part is that I can
choose alpha beta gamma and tall to be
all the same that is there's one set of
alpha beta gamma and tall that works for
everything for all four points so you
look at that puzzled and that's okay to
be puzzled because I certainly haven't
proven that maturity that but right away
there's something interesting about this
and that is that the relationship
between the points on the unknown object
and the points and the stored library of
images are related linearly that's true
because it's orthographic projection
linearly related so I can generate the
points in the in some fourth object from
the points in three sample objects with
a linear operations Christopher is that
the x-coordinate of it's the answer
it's the x-coordinate each of those
export Christopher asks about the x
coordinates each of these x coordinates
are meant to be color-coded it gets a
little complicated with the notation and
stuff so that's the reason I'm color
kind of color encoding the coordinates
so that the so the orange X sub u is the
x coordinate of that particular point if
we know in not in 3d space in the image
it's a 2d projection an orthographic
projection okay so what we're looking at
drawings and those coordinates over
there are the two dimensional
coordinates in the drawing just as if we
were on your retina so yes about fur
services and the answer is that you have
to find corresponding points on the
object so if you had a curved if you
have a totally curved surface you can't
identify any corresponding points you
lose but if you consider our faces there
are some obvious points even though our
faces are not by any means flat like
these objects we have the tip of our
nose and the center of our eyeballs and
so on so if that's true what does that
mean about recovering Alpha Beta Gamma
and tall can we can we find them not
only what do you think how we'll go
about finding them you're nodding your
head in the right direction
splendid it's four equations and four
enough for T or phrases in four notes so
obviously you can solve for alpha beta
gamma and and talk if you know that
these equations are correct so how does
that help us with recognition
it helps us with recognition because we
can take another point let me say the
square point here and this corresponding
square point here and this corresponding
square point here and what we do with
those three points now we've got Alpha
Beta Gamma and tall so we can predict
where it's going to be in the fourth
image so we can predict that that square
point is going to be right there and if
it isn't we are highly suspicious about
whether this object is the kind of
object we think it is so you look at me
in disbelief you like me to should
demonstrate this I'm
okay let me see if I can demonstrate
this
so I'm going to do this in a slightly
simplified in a slightly simplified
version I'm only going to allow rotation
around the around the vertical axis and
just so you know I'm not cheating
there's a little slider here that
rotates that that third object let's see
why are there just two two known objects
and one unknown well that's because I've
restricted the motion to rotation around
the vertical axis and some translation
so now that I've spun that around a
little bit let me pick some
corresponding points oops what's
happened
well let me run that by again
okay so there's one point I've selected
from the model objects and the
corresponding point over here on the
unknown is right there I'm going to be a
little off but that's okay so let me
pick that one and then this that
corresponds to this one Krishna would
you like to specify a point so that
people know though I'm just cheating no
I'm not cheating pick a point pick a
play Krishna right this one oops I just
pick out a model first now pick it over
here
boom so all the points are where they're
supposed to be Matt cool well let's
suppose that the unknown is something
else this is a carefully selected object
because the points are all the correct
positions vertically but they're not
necessarily the correct positions in the
other two dimensions so let me pick up
at this point at this point at this
point at this point and Krishna have you
picked this point so we pick this point
so if it thinks that the unknown is one
of these obelisk objects then we would
expect to see all of the corresponding
points correctly identified but boom all
the points are off so it seems to work
in this particular example I find the
Alpha and Beta using two images and I
predict the locations of the other
points and I determine whether those
positions are correct and if they are
correct then a pretty good idea that I
have in fact identified the object on
the right is either an obelisk or an
organ depending on which of the model
choices and the unknown choices I've
selected so the only thing I have to
left to do is to demonstrate that what I
said about this is true so I'm going to
actually demonstrate that what I said
about this is true
using the
configuration in this demonstration
because it's much too hard for me to
remember matrix transformations for
generalized rotation around three and
three dimensions so here's how it's
going to work
the z-axis is going up that way or it's
going to be pointing toward you and what
I'm going to do is I'm going to rotate
around this axis and what I'm going to
do what I want to do is I want to find
out how the x coordinate in the image of
the points move as I do that rotation so
here's the x axis this is the coordinate
that you can see here is the y axis
that's in depth so you can't tell how
far away it is and their z axis XY z
axis must be pointing out that way
toward you so now I'm going to consider
just a single point on the object and
see what happens to it so I'm going to
sis I'm going to say to myself let's put
it in some kind of standard let's put
the object in some kind of standard
position I don't care what it is but it
can be just random just spinning around
some position we call that the standard
position s and that means that the x
coordinate of the standard position is X
sub s and a y-coordinate of the standard
position is a Y sub s and now I'm going
to rotate the object three times once to
form the a picture once to form the B
picture and once to form the C picture
and you can make those choices I don't
have you know I don't have to put those
can be anything right so let's say that
the a picture is out here so that's X
that's that's the a picture to be
picture is out here and the unknown is
up that way
and so what I want to know depends on
these vectors we'll call that theta sub
a and this is theta sub E oops yeah that
status a B and this one is theta sub u
so I would like to know how X sub a
depends on X sub s and Y sub s and I can
never remember how to do that because I
can never remember the transformation
equations for rotation so I have to
figure it out every time and this is no
exception so what I'm going to say is it
this vector that goes out to s consists
of two pieces there's the X part and the
y part and I know that I can rotate this
vector by alpha sub a by rotating this
vector and rotating that vector and
adding up the results right so if I
rotate this vector by alpha sub a then
the contribution of that to the
x-coordinate of a is going to be given
by the cosine of theta sub a multiplied
by X sub s right so you can just
exaggerate that move motion say well if
I pitch it up that way and the
projection down on the on the x axis is
going to be this length of the vector
times the cosine of the angle all right
now there's also going to be a
dependence on Y sub s let's figure out
what that's going to be I've got this
vector here I'm going to rotate it by
theta sub a as well if I rotate that by
theta the way and see what the
projection is on the x axis that's going
to be given by the sine of the of the
angle right but it's actually it's going
the wrong way so I have to subtract it
off so that's how I don't have to
remember what the signs are in these
equations
well that was good and now I can now
walk now the ball for money I can do
what I did before it makes it easy to do
give the lecture because this is going
to be X to B is equal to X sub s times
the cosine of theta sub B minus y sub s
times the cosine of theta
hope you're letting me make mistakes
sham this is I can generally tell by all
the troubled looks but there should be
some shouting as well it's the sine and
that's the sine and one more time
X sub U is equal to X sub s times the
cosine of theta sub u minus y sub s
times the sine of theta sub u and I
forgot to be up there so there are some
equations and we don't know we're doing
we're just going to stare around them
awhile and see if they sing us a song so
let's see if these thing is the song
what about X ma and X sub e these are
things that we see in the image these
are things that we can measure
what about all those cosines and sines
and feita a s and theta B's well we have
no idea what they are but one thing is
clear they're true for all the points on
the object because when we rotate the
object around by angle theta we're
rotating all the points the same but
through the same angle right so with
respect to any particular view of the
object here we are under standard
position here we are in position a the
vectors to all of the points on the
object are rotated by the same angle
when we go from the standard position to
the a position so that means that for
all of the all of the images in this
particular rendering with a particular
rotation by theta a theta B and theta
you those are constants now remember
this is for a particular theta a a
particular theta B in a particular theta
you as long as the we're talking about
all the points for each of those
rotations those angles and cosines are
going to be the same for all possible
for all possible points on the object
okay so now we go back to our high
school algebra experts and we say look
at these first two equations we can get
rid of we can we can express well we
have two equations and what we can now
conceive can screw to beat to a knows
what are the unknowns that are left we
could measure a and B whatever the
cosines are they're the same for all the
pictures so if we treat those as
constants then we can solve for X of s
and Y sub s right we can solve for X of
s and Y sub s and turn into the X sub a
and right and X to B and and a whole and
a whole bunch of constants
but I don't know a whole bunch of
constants let's see we can gather up all
those cosines and ratios sines and
cosines and all that stuff and I'll put
them all together because they're all
constants and then we can do this we can
say X of U is equal to well it's going
to depend on X of a and X to be and by
the time we wash our maybe later screw
around with all those Co sides we can
say that the multiplier for X sub a is
some constant alpha and a multiplier for
X to be is some constant data so that's
not a sleight of hand that's just linear
manipulation of those equations and
that's what we wanted to show that for
orthographic projection which is that
which this is there's no perspective
involved here we're just taking the
projection along the x axis for that
kind of projection then we can
demonstrate for this simplified
situation that that equation must hold
now I want to give you a few puzzles
because it's something so simple
suppose I allow translation as well as
rotation what's going to happen yeah you
got it you got a constant towel but what
do we need to do in order to solve these
let's see how to get three unknowns
right
I don't know tall I don't know
exhibition I don't know my stuff so I
need another equation where do I get the
other equation from another picture
that's why up it up there
I needed four points that covers a
situation where I've got three degrees
of rotation and translation here I got
by with just two pictures in this
illustration that one involved at all a
translational element so I needed three
pictures and this one's got full
rotation so I need four so great idea
works fine trouble is it doesn't work so
fine on natural objects it works fine on
things that are manufactured because
they all have identical dimensions so if
I made a million of these in a factory
I'd have no trouble recognizing them
because all I have to do is take three
pictures reporter coordinates of some of
the points and I'll be done
trouble is the natural world isn't like
this and you are like this either
I don't know if you know if I'm trying
to recognize faces and so it's not that
easy to to do all this first of all it's
a little difficult to find the exact
point the exactly corresponding points I
made that I made a mistake in doing it
myself and if the computer made a
mistake it would we certainly make an
error because it would be using non
corresponding points to make predictions
it would be way off but this is still in
the tradition of working from the from
local features in the objects toward
recognition so having
having looked at that theory we also
find it a little wanting works great in
some circumstances doesn't seem to solve
the whole recognition problem years pass
shamone omen comes up with another
theory that's not so much based on edge
fragments or the location of particular
features but rather on correlation
taking a picture of say krishna's face
taking a picture of the whole class and
then using that as a kind of correlation
mask running it all over the picture of
the class seeing where it maximizes out
that's vague I'll explain what I'm
talking about
despite the correlation in a minute but
it's basically saying do I have if I
have a picture of Krishna where do I
find them I'll find them in one place
you know what Krishna doesn't look like
anybody else so I might not find any
other faces and my objective is to find
all the faces then maybe that idea won't
work either or to take another example
here's a dollar bill we haven't had
raises in quite a while so this is my
last one it's got a picture of George
Washington on it and I can look all over
the class and and if I use this as a
face detector be sorely disappointed
because I wouldn't find any faces
because thank God nobody looks exactly
like George Washington so the
correlation would work very well so that
idea is a loser the wait a minute I
don't have to look for the whole face I
could I could just look for eyeball for
eyes and then I could look for noses and
maybe mouths and maybe I have a library
of ten different eyes and ten different
noses and ten different mouths would
that idea work
probably not so well trouble with that
one is I'd find eyeballs in every
doorknob it's just not enough stuff
there to to give me a reliable
correlation so let's make this a little
more concrete by drawing some pictures
Halloween is approaching so here's a
face all right here's another face
so those that might be faces in my
pre-recorded library of funk and faces
now along comes this face
what's going to happen well I don't know
let's try to get another face
I don't know it could be a pretty weird
problem your face I suppose but I mean
it to be something that doesn't look
very much like a face so if I'm doing a
complete correlation with either of
these faces in my library neither one
will match this one very well all right
if I'm looking for fine features like
eyes then I've got these eyes everywhere
so it doesn't help very much so you can
see where I'm going you can read that
almonds great idea what is it we don't
look for big features like whole faces
we don't look for small features like
individual eyes we look for intermediate
features like two eyes and a nose or a
mouth and a nose so when we do that then
we can say well here are two eyes in the
nose up that's found in this one and
what about the combination of that nose
and that mouth oh that's over here and
neither of those features can be found
in the third in the fourth image so
that's the Goldilocks principle when
you're doing this sort of thing you want
things are not too small not too big
I've got the Rumplestiltskin picked the
Rumplestiltskin principle up there too
by the way because I meant to mention
that Marr was a genius at naming things
and even though many of his theories
have faded he's still known for these
names like primal sketch into a nasty
sketch because he was such an artist at
naming the concepts he even got credit
for a lot of stuff that he didn't do not
because he was deliberately trying to to
to get it inappropriately but just
because he was so good at naming stuff
so he had the Rumpelstiltskin principle
back then and now we have the Goldilocks
principle not too big not too small
but that leaves us with the final
question which is okay so if what we
want to do is look for intermediate size
features how do we actually find them in
a sea if a sea of faces out there see I
might have a library I might take ten of
you and record your eyes take another
ten record your mouth and they may be
put together in a unique way for each of
you out there but it's it's is likely
that I'll find Juana's eyes somewhere
else in a crowd and niccola's mouth
somewhere else in the ground so how do
we in fact go about finding them and I
mentioned the term correlation a couple
of times now let me let me make that
concrete so let's to consider a a one
dimensional face that looks like this
it's just a signal and I'm going to
consider a one-dimensional image and in
that one dimensional image I've got a
facsimile of the face and the question
is what kind of algorithm can I use to
determine the offset in the image where
the face occurs and so you can you can
see that one possibility is you just do
an integral of the signal in the face
and the signal out here over the extent
of the face and and see how it
multiplies out or to make it less
literally a more MIT ish let's say that
what we're going to do is we're going to
maximize over some parameter X the
integral over X of some face which is a
function of X and the image G which is a
function of X minus that offset so when
T when the offset T is equal to this
offset then we're essentially
multiplying the thing by itself and
integrating over the extent of the face
and that gives you a very big number if
they're lined up and a very small number
if they're not and it's even true if we
add a whole lot of noise to the images
but these are images they're not
one-dimensional that's okay it's easy
enough to make a modification here I'm
going to maximize over translation
parameters X and Y and these are no
longer functions of just X they're also
functions of wife
like so all right so that's that's
basically how it works I mean we'll go
into details about normalization all
that sort of thing because that's the
stuff of which other courses remain the
custodians so well would you like to see
demonstration ok
all right so without realizing it Nicola
and Erica have loaned us their pictures
and they are embedded in that big field
of noise and it's pretty easy to pick
out Erica Nicola right because we are
actually pretty good at picking cases
out of these so out of these images so
um let's add some noise it's a little
harder now what I'm going to do is I'm
going to run this correlation program
over this whole image using Nicolas face
as a mask and seeing where the
correlation hit Peaks up in spite of all
the noises in there boom there he is
okay I don't notice maybe we can find
Erica - I forgot where she was and I
can't find her as she is - unfortunately
the parameters aren't very good here do
you see that do you see that let me get
a another version of this just do some
so do some real-time programming
I've been trying to reset the parameters
so they come out so that the images a
demonstration comes out clearly up there
see this works a little better ok so
let's add some noise and let's find
Erica there she is okay there are some
other things that look a little bit like
Erica but nothing looks quite exactly
like Erica so let's try it on niccola's
eyes so they stand out pretty clearly
against the background let's see if we
can find Erica's eyes so they stand out
pretty clearly against the background
notice it also gets Nichols eyes so two
eyes
is it intermediate-sized constraint it's
loose enough that it will match more
than one person but it's not so loose
that it's as bad as looking for one I
see they're all over the place so two
eyes and a nose a mouth and the nose
that would be even better as an
intermediate feature but it doesn't
matter what the best ones are because
you work that out experimentally so
that's how correlation works and it's
just amazing how much noise you can add
and you'll still pick out the right the
right stuff there's Nicola boom very
clear I'm going to add some more noise I
don't know I I can see it but that's
because I'm a pretty good correlator -
boom I don't know let's add some more
noise
it's just how hard to get rid of it and
it's just amazing how well it picks it
up that's that's good that's cool now
how could you uh but this division that
this is thirty years and we're still not
done is there still some questions
this is recognizing stuff straight on
how is it I can recognize you in the
hall from the side
nobody knows one possibility is that you
have an ability to make those
transformations if so then that
alignment theory has a role to play
another theory is that
well after I've seen you once I can
watch you turn your head and keep
recording what you look like at all
possible angles that would work
trouble is is there enough stuff in
there maybe we don't know now what would
it take to break this mechanism well I
don't know let's just see if we can
break the mechanism let's say for you
can recognize some well-known faces
whose that quick
oh that's too easy I will see if we can
make some harder ones yeah that's a
llama who's this oh boy you really good
at this that's Bush how about this guy
okay now I've got it some people are
starting to turn their heads and that's
not fair that's not fair
as you see what's happened is that if
this if this kind of pumpkin theory is
correct then when you turn to face
upside down
you'll lose the correlation of those
features that have vertical components
so if you have two eyes and the nose
they won't match two eyes in the nose
when I turned upside down well let's see
try some more who's that
Gorbachev who said that Leonid where are
you suburban sharp right you can
recognize him because of that little
birthmark on its top of his head one
more
who's that's easy right who's it
that's uh that's Clinton how about this
one you see how insulting it is to be at
MIT that's me and you didn't even know
Oh God
so this suggests that this might be
evidence for the correlation theory but
of course turning the face upside down
would make it very difficult to do
alignment to so would break our limit
theory as well let me do that after
classifier and it was a mistake while
we're breaking from what stretches
the LEDs have stretching would break the
correlation and and the answer is I
think stretching in the vertical
dimension is worse than stretching in
the horizontal dimension as you get a
certain amount of stretching in the
horizontal dimension when you just turn
your head by the way since our faces are
basically mounted on a cylinder this
kind of transformation might actually
work it's a sidebar to the answer to
your question le but now you say well
okay so this is not completely solved
you can you can work this out but if you
really want to work something out let me
tell you what the current what the
current questions are in computer vision
people work for an awful long time in
this recognition stuff and to my mind
I've neglected the more serious
questions as more serious questions are
how do you visually determine what's
happening if you could write a program
that would reliably determine when these
verbs are happening in your field of
view I will I will sign your PhD thesis
tomorrow there are 48 of them there and
that is today's challenge but since
we're short on time I want to skip over
that and perform an experiment are you I
want you to tell me what I'm doing
so this best single word answer is - aw
okay it's not a trick question
and that's not the word answer
Christopher what do you think
Christopher well you you
what towstee okay not a trick question
what's happening here best single word
answer mystery which pair look more
alike so that cat is drinking and nobody
has any trouble recognizing that and I
believe it's because I believe it's
because you're telling a story so our
power of storytelling even reaches down
into our visual apparatus so the story
here is that some animal has evidently
added urge to find something to drink
and water is passing through that
animal's mouth that's the drinking story
so even though they look enormous ly
different visually the stuff at the
bottom of our vision system provides
enough evidence for our story apparatus
so that we can give the left one and the
right one different labels and recognize
the cat is drinking and that's the end
of the story
you
you